favorite he has reached the top speed of
23.5 mph this season his average speed
this is where he excels look at
that this just looks different look at
his feet never stop moving never stop
looks different never stop moving
well there's a winner winner chicken
parm
dinner the ability for him to hold the
edges in the corners at top speed is
what separates him from most of the
players in the National Hockey League
and that was on full display right there
he grew up in the Toronto area he did
Nick a couple pylons mess but those
things are light didn't affect him at
all didn't affect him fourth win in this
competition most all time he can uh like
I said if he puts his if he puts his
heart into it and he really goes for it
I don't think there's a faster scared in
the National Hockey League and this is
why right here watching his feet through
the corners but being able to hold the
edge at top
speed a lot of strength a lot of skill a
lot of practice but is doing this drill
right here so this could be an advantage
for him because this is what he trains
on this is one of his suggestions to the
NHL when the two sides got together to
try to make this skills competition a
little better for the fans create some
drama some nervousness maybe for the
players cuz they're playing for 1
million bucks no one does this look look
at the speed he does it
with now he's going to wheel quickly who
little stumble on the edge there
you see the you can see the transition
is not quite as smooth as as as a
defenseman right but still not too bad I
thought K would do this one as well
try's he's going to beat Hughes oh my
goodness
[Applause]
unbelievable the acceleration is just
insane he is clearly taken this
seriously he does everything he wants to
win this I more than anybody out there I
believe a little stumble on the left
skate there
and then just make sure you get the job
done there and finish Mar's point total
might freeze there at 15 the guys under
the cut have to really pour it on
McDavid wants to continue getting points
he wants the overall Championship one
for one two for two three for three can
he do it yes oh
tremendous oh and quick
and you see this the way he shot it with
velocity 9158 the new
[Applause]
leader all right M you said go low
first yeah you in an order he did he
went around the clock around the world
boom really like the way he attacked the
target so remember he already has two
first tonight that's one of the tie
Breakers later is how many firsts you
get if you're tied with a guy in total
points debating it but now we're going
to find
out well a lot of people call this the
Conor McDavid Invitational if there was
no salary cap on the Range we paying him
50 million so this is a way to get Conor
an extra million bucks let's see I think
he wants to win 47 seconds for a million
dollar it's a good start oh just misses
the this is the narrow one this is the
hardest one he got it now this is an
easy one for him that's a piece of cake
he's going to do it just don't fall down
Conor you're going to win a million
[Applause]
dollarss don't fall down
Conor and put the biscuit in the basket
$1 million shot here it is oh no
problem what a
performance what a performance by what
we thought was the best player in the
National Hockey League debatable maybe
for some but now we know
BCI incredible
incredible I love the
compet $1 million to Conor McDavid the
man who help reimagine the event bring
some
[Applause]
juice